look at the blood spatter bang-bang-bang
My name is Matthew Steiner Matt Steiner
is a senior crime scene analyst and
veteran investigator of over 21 years
today we're gonna break down the
portrayal of forensic science and TV and
movies as we're critiquing these clips
understand that their goal is to
entertain and they definitely do that
the wire trajectory analysis
first off the gun safety and this was it
was comical and not realistic you
wouldn't take a loaded weapon and start
waving around at a crime scene initially
the original crime scene investigator on
the scene should've took note of
directionality
we do that by looking at the Concordia
fracturing of glass to see which
direction of force is going off oh so we
would have known in this case originally
that the bullet was coming from outside
to the inside of the kitchen so what
they do from that point is they try to
figure what would the trajectory line be
from that bullet hole through her
deceased body which way was that bullet
going fuckin'-a lo and behold there is
the bullet in the door from
that point I think we deviate from
reality but we wouldn't just start
picking at that hole they could be
destroying rifling that's on that bolt
and that's what really we're going to
sent in a lab to do some sort of
analysis compared to a suspects gun
NCIS personal protective
equipment
no rule number two is always wear gloves
but when there's this much blood
reindeer in the truck so in this scene
they actually talk about wearing
personal protective equipment Rainier
yet no one is wearing any sort of garb
what happened everyone is wearing just
like a jumpsuit or the regular tire and
just gloves basically you would never
want to do that apparently that was
beyond that our crime-scene technician
he's taking photographs he then wipes
his brow Danny handles Ebbets basically
what he's done he's taken DNA that was
on that camera on his brow and put it on
to our evidence on the scene and then
proceeded to have a whole conversation
while holding that evidence right by his
face you see the counselor that's a
pretty good movie again improper
procedure for collection of DNA evidence
he could have been wearing a tie back
suit a mask you may even want to wear
goggles or glasses and multiple layers
of gloves
rule number two is always wear clothes I
would strip out the outer layer of
gloves put another layer of gloves on
top of it and then proceed to collect
evidence I think I found that out boss
recovering evidence zodiac initial
observations is that the vehicle might
have been wiped down which you can see
sometimes with oblique lighting and a
scene you can see sometimes fingerprints
so that's a pretty good observation
thank you as we proceed the other side
of the vehicle there's a shell casing on
the driver's side front floor which
wasn't marked or photographed as far as
I could tell oh well that's good if
things got to be documented in situ or
as is as found he just picks it up with
a pen where is that pen been beforehand
you know was it in your hand was it in
your ear was it in your nose it's got
DNA from who knows where I don't know
where this started unfortunately I've
seen this in real life if anything if
this is like a PSA of what not to do at
a crime scene that's one of those big
things you wouldn't want to do at a
crime scene an idiot tire impression
evidence the flash getaway cars and
Mustang Shelby gt500 Shelby's have a
rear super-wide tire specific to that
model 12 inches with an asymmetrical
tread I don't think anyone with just by
looking at a tire impression to say it
came from a specific vehicle sorry we
went do some sort of dental stone
casting of that impression recover it
send to the lab and then there's
database which they can search to say
what sort of vehicles it could come from
there's something else and there's a pen
again being used to collect evidence
like that gave me that pen which was
improper before he died
another thing you wouldn't do is if
anything is inside of our impression at
our scene we would leave it there we
would cast it in place we wouldn't
sample it because you could be
destroying tread we're inside that
impression yeah yeah after he samples
with the pen fecal excrement animal I
guess I don't know how he would know the
difference between human and animal
feces which I don't think is realistic
no loaded weapon examining a body
[Music]
so what are we looking at here doc the
worst dress tip I've ever seen this
stiff and I found it a beat together for
five years so show some respect so it's
common for TV and movies to present
crime-scene investigation in this
fashion where we have all these
different people doing a million
different things all at once inside of a
crime scene that means it's working we
want that crime scene clear we wouldn't
want anyone in there except the people
who are doing the investigation in real
life not that we would make fun of
someone who is dead show some respect
but there is a certain gallows humor
that goes along with crime scene
investigation and death investigation
and it's one of the ways to cope with it
is to adopt this type of humor I know
crime scene analysis as portrayed in
boondocks aids you got any theories time
he was the only one done right double
tap back of the head
independence new hit man wants to leave
his mark that's a possibility
another possibility is they were placed
there with Aitchison camped in the scene
they focus too much on the why the crime
happened what is this their crime scene
analysis usually deals with the who the
what the where oh I forgot about
that one when the howl of something but
never the walk and it makes me feel like
river dancing the Y has to do it motive
and there's no way that we can prove why
with science heat crime-scene analysis
this guy here he's got what appears to
be a DoubleTap entry wound to the
sternum tattooing around the head wound
scorched the bone close-range probably
executed in this scene we have our I'm
assuming he's a crime scene investigator
he makes an assumption that a gunshot
entry wound was that close range and if
you're willing to the sternum close
range we can make those determinations
when you fire a gun
besides the bullet that comes out of the
barrel we have burning an unburned
gunpowder what difference does it make
that burning gunpowder will go a certain
distance we then also have
unburned gunpowder that goes a further
distance to that and then obviously the
bullet goes the furthest is bang bang
bang so we'll look at the injuries we'll
look at whether there is burning and
then we'll look for other things like
stippling and that is the operations
caused by the unburned gunpowder
operating the skin what about them not
having a weapon itself you really
couldn't say exactly but we could take
that weapon in the same ammunition bring
it to ballistics and do so
test firings at different distances to
replicate that pattern to see we get the
same diameter of gunshot residue and
burning rock-and-roll fingerprint
evidence this is kind of overkill it's
probably because it looked cool the
reason they put the alternate light
source in there with fluorescent powder
it really could have kept doing just
regular black powder probably is what we
would have done in the field
it's like prescribing brain surgery for
headaches out there beyond that the
techniques aren't that great because
they're using too much powder and then
you're using compressed air to blow out
to friction Ridge detail we would never
do that
Jodie Foster told me also right here he
calls it a swirl pattern there's no such
thing as a swirl pattern there's arches
loops and whorls so there's some parts
of this that are true but a lot of it is
fans
what is his mummy doing processing a
vehicle the other guy we found a lot of
stuff bodily fluid and hair samples we
determined that a bunch of old homeless
dudes had an orgy in the car so what
they get right in the scene is that
they're processing indoors they bring
into a garage and that's what you want
to do in real life yeah and then the top
it all off some joker comes along I
think he knew you guys were cops because
this is what I would call a spite
also the attire of our crime-scene
technicians is correct oh yeah they're
all wearing personal protective
equipment Tyvek suits gloves masks dirty
Mike and the boys which is funny it's a
comedy but they got it right I'm a dear
vagina the rest of it is just kind of
silly and funny determining you know
that it was a spaceship or that you know
there was a deer vagina what or homeless
guys had an orgy inside the car it's
just kind of funny but very unrealistic
turned my beautiful prints into a
nightmare how to get away with murder
detecting latent blood
[Music]
they didn't find it so in this clip way
too many people inside this crime scene
all doing random things at once just
like we saw with the loaded weapon cliff
some people have gloves on some people
don't no one is wearing a tie Vic suit
or booties and probably the biggest
cardinal sin is that we have the suspect
inside the scene how much longer you
know that's not reality at all what they
start pulling out knives out of a knife
block and a swab but they swab one side
of the blade not the other side of the
blade nor do they swab the handle seems
like a foolish move the last step was to
do luminol testing and that's a chemical
we used inside of crime scenes to look
for late in blood everyone want to be
cleared out of the room at that point is
a possibility that luminol is
carcinogenic so you'd be wearing a mask
as well as Tyvek suit oh you're being
paranoid but you know you just start
randomly spraying the chemicals and
everyone else is around breathing it
that's a no-no and maybe he's just being
smart also using some sort of UV light
with it or some sort of blue light with
it luminol you don't need that you don't
need any sort of alternate light source
you just make the room dark you spray it
in combination with hydrogen peroxide
and if there's a reaction it will glow
I'm gonna run what's called a luminol
test so this is where they actually do
get it right later on he's called out
for diluting the blood by spraying too
much luminol the more luminol you spray
the more you dilute the blood real life
we'd be very careful on how much of the
chemical we're gonna add there's other
chemicals that will react in glow or
chemiluminescent ooh luminol okay all
right I get it
ballistic and fingerprint analysis the
dark night that's Brooke underneath I'm
gonna take ballistics off the shouted
bullet no thank you
recovery technique is pretty good we
would try to cut it out of the wall
[Music]
this is your original scam do it is
reengineered there's the thumbprint left
when you pushed around in the clip this
is completely impossible yeah there's
not based on any sort of science and the
rifling inside the barrel is gonna
create markings on that bullet which
would have destroyed a fingerprint that
was there anyway let alone the extreme
heat that would have burned off most of
the fingerprint good luck let's same
pattern analysis as portrayed in Dexter
the male victim was standing right here
and the killer plunged his knife into
the shoulder severing the carotid artery
and here and assume yep Dexter doing
blood stain pattern analysis so over
here you have nice clean sprays of blood
he gets the description a categorization
of the blood same patterns correctly but
that's really about it
first off those types of patterns you
would never do that sort of
reconstruction floor you would never do
stringing for arterial or gushing or
cast-off because there's no way that you
could figure out exactly where it came
from
okay never know as opposed to some sort
of impact spatter from a gunshot or for
someone that was beaten with a bat so
we're looking for a sushi chef looks
like just someone just took a bucket of
red paint and threw it on one wall and
then someone kind of randomly squirted
blood on another wall this week a finger
painting then cast-off they don't look
realistic they're a little more linear
than that they sometimes can be
curvilinear depending on how you're
moving your hand but to say it
definitely came from a sharp knife not a
sword there's there's not really in a
way to say the exact object that it came
from yes sushi chef is possible insomnia
autopsy clear cause of death was
herniation of the brainstem due to into
cerebral hemorrhage beaten to death
these contusions superficial most of the
trauma was to her face in the top of her
neck
first up what I don't like about the
portrayal of this which they do
sometimes in these shows is that
someone's got to turn on a light not
this time yeah we'd want as much light
as possible told you it didn't appear
that there was an even an autopsy done
who's gonna be there was no Y incision
on our deceased so to say that the neck
injury is superficial
how would you even know that without
actually looking at it to see how the
part of that tissue is damaged or if the
hyoid bone was broken or fractured
there's no way to know just by doing a
visual inspection to see that sort of
thing okay buddy gave us nothing at the
end you know he's handling the body
takes his clothes off and then touch
her hair she could be bleeding from the
head and now you're taking your bare
hand and touching her blood didn't even
blink and then maybe later on having a
sandwich or whatever so it's kind of
ridiculous it's good across the line
crime scene assumptions true detective
this is gonna happen again this is his
vision her body is a paraphilic love map
they might not have known her but this
idea goes way back with him I get that
from one of your books I did I got to
thank Woody Harrelson for this he
basically says what I'm gonna say anyway
you got a chapter in one of those books
I'm jumping to conclusions any time we
start an investigation with an
assumption or we come up with a theory
I'm guaranteed an s-curve we always have
to be ready to abandon that theory you
attach an assumption to a piece of
evidence you start to bend the narrative
to support it what I like about this
clip is that woody houses character kind
of stops which I got a problem with Bone
Collector collection of evidence we're
gonna need those handcuffs immunity well
then we can remove them when they get
here look in the suitcase there's a
small saw I want you to saw her hands
off at the wrist line this is not
realistic at all we would never destroy
the body intentionally like that it's
true to recover handcuffs we would
somehow get those removes off her hands
and she takes a couple seconds to try to
remove them they're stuck so the next
option is to cut off the victims hands
no they're still gonna be blood that's
gonna be coming out of the other end of
that hand which is gonna completely
consume whatever DNA or fingerprints
that would be on the handcuffs so not a
great option hey why don't you knock it
off like I don't need to knock it off
forensic anthropology Castle yo
this building was set to be demolished
that is until the salvage crews
stripping the place came across his body
buried under concrete no less guy cause
of death I tell I do a full exam but
he's probably been here since they
poured the concrete back in 1978
anything else you can tell us about them
he was maybe early thirties and a sharp
dresser check out that powder-blue suit
in this scene they're able to somehow
miraculously perfectly excavate this
skeleton fully intact there another
concrete no less unlikely what if you
were to be breaking up concrete with
sledge hammers or jackhammer you would
have already damaged it probably crushed
a rib cage if not a bunch of the bones I
know who the victim is what beyond that
to give it a general age estimation I
think that is possible he was maybe
early thirties your skeleton is going to
age in a very predictable manner I'm
intrigued so that's what they look for
certain growth in and deterioration of
bone and a testament to the truly
indestructible nature polyester early
forensic investigations in cold blood
find a shell casings no didn't leave any
fingerprints either first off we can
note that they're not wearing any sort
of personal protective equipment or we
wouldn't want to just take powder and
just pour it onto a surface and then
dust that powder around man would take
that powder and put it onto a separate
clean surface it's not related to the
scene at all do other than that they
make an assumption that casings were
cleaned up somehow or picked up initial
occasion could have been a revolver
semi-automatic automatic weapon casings
gonna be a ejected out of the side of
that weapon but a revolver that casings
gonna stay inside so that would be the
reason why you might not have a shell
casing at the scene probably Criminal
Minds crime scene analysis chained
Bernie and Vinny a dev were here Jane
tried to run Vinny I didn't how do you
know she's half under her desk which
means she tried to hide an enzyme found
it
one of the worst things you could do as
a crime-scene investigator is to lose
your objectivity what if she was just
sitting at the desk is that the position
she died in maybe she crawled to her
desk so these three were stabbed and the
rest were shot to death they also make
an assumption that we have one unknown
subject or killer as opposed to two have
you considered two killers yes bloody
footprints all seem to come from the
same pair of shoes it's possible that
someone else didn't step in blood right
yes or that they both wore the same pair
of shoes we see this a lot you would
have to recover those shoe wear
impressions and analyzing the left which
is a quick visual analysis couldn't give
you that information evidence at a crime
scene Family Guy and now back to Jake
and The Fatman Hey look over here on the
carpet
that's a cigarette butt this is probably
evidence yeah can you bring it over to
me I can't move it this is a crime scene
so what we see in here is the typical
chalk outline where the body was its
iconic look can you describe it to me
but it's a joke no one does that anymore
you're destroying evidence you could be
adding chalk on top of DNA that could be
important or are the trace evidence that
could be important
you know what forget it Iron Man 3 the
use of virtual reality and crime scene
analysis 3,000 degrees Celsius any
subjects within 12.5 yards were
vaporized instantly no bomb parts found
in the three mile radius of the Chinese
Theater no sir this is something that
could happen maybe not to that extent
that we see in Iron Man 3 but there is
current research in the use of virtual
reality and augmented reality to help
assist crime scene investigators I'm
happy so if we document our scene with
the three-dimensional laser scanner the
laser scanner is gonna collect millions
and millions of points of data and we'd
be able to see anything that's in the
view of that scanner that at the end
we're one with the three-dimensional
model we could then take ourselves
virtually through VR technology place
ourselves in a scene to make
observations and those are the
observations that we've used for a
reconstruction where as evidence what's
the context of this evidence what
happened and what order did things
happen its pageantry going on here lots
Theatres minor report predictive crime
analysis time horizon 12 minutes
what he's doing now we call scrubbing
the image looking for clues as to where
the murder is gonna happen
beyond that the date of the crime all we
have to run out of the images that they
produce so in this movie we see our
precogs our psychics producing images of
crimes that haven't happened yet precogs
can see a murder four days out now I
don't think that that is ever possible
but there is cutting-edge research and
technology that does help us identify
crimes in progress oh this is good one
of those technologies is what's called
shot spotter that identifies audio from
gunshots and specific to gunshots
happening at certain areas and giving it
a GPS location it's a park Dutch police
are using augmented and virtual reality
to go back and look at crime scenes in
the past to help in their analysis and
reconstruction conclusion with the
increased popularity of these types of
shows the public's perception has been
affected by it both in positive and
negative ways on the positive side we
have more people coming into the field
and more attention is being given to
forensic science and a negative side
things are always shown absolutes the
timeline of analysis is not true and not
correct techniques and technology that
just not even scientifically valid and
does not exist now I understand that the
goal of this is strictly for
entertainment and it does that